Todd McShea from the mothership ESPN
draft analyst joins us now Todd thanks
for joining us would you explain do you
make predictions of what you think teams
will do or do you say what they should
be doing well we've done both in the
past but usually the mantra is you're
trying to make a prediction of what the
team will do at the end of the day and
as we get closer it's you spend more
time on the phone just talking to GM's
personnel directors and getting a feel
that no one's I never asked and no one's
gonna tell you exactly what they're
gonna take and and outside of Cleveland
at 1:00 they don't know who they're
gonna be dealing with what players are
gonna be available when they pick so you
try to get a range try to kind of over
conversations in time figure out which
players they kind of lean towards and
try to put the pieces of the puzzle
together
okay let's start with Cleveland with Sam
Donald you think they will take Sam
Donald should they take Sam Donald I
don't know I I keep I keep hearing Alan
and here's the thing I I don't know why
that they why they would send out
messages or John Dorsey would kind of
hint towards one player or nod but why
it would matter because it's not like
any teams moving up to take that pick
they're locked in but he's he's
notoriously tight-lipped about this
stuff
and I think it should be Donald but I I
keep hearing now as we get closer and
closer more and more whispers about Josh
Allen being attacked what's interesting
too is I take the Giants for example
they're sitting at number two I'm told
that the only way they would take a
quarterback at number two is if Donald
was available but Cleveland could pass
on them take Allen the Jets would take
Darnell if he's available I'm told if
not it's probably going to be Baker
Mayfield and so the Jets have interest
in Mayfield Denver five has interest in
Mayfield
I'm cold Miami has a lot of interest in
Mayfield the Buffalo Bills if they move
up probably more Allen or Josh Rosen and
like I said Cleveland could line up with
Allen whereas there are several other
teams that would jump at the chance to
take Sam Darnell so it really is amazing
with these four quarterbacks
the different points of view and the
different interest that teams have taken
best player in the draft is who say Guam
Berkeley okay
Penn State running back no I would lump
into that top-tier court Nelson the
guard from Notre Dame and Bradley child
NC State defensive end
I think Chubb is he's just I hate the
work safe but you talk about a guy that
defend the run he's a high-level pass
rusher great motor practice player you
know he just brings everything to the
table that you're looking for and so the
beauty is if your team like Denver five
or even Cleveland it for because at
least two quarterbacks are gonna go in
the top three you're gonna wind up
getting maybe the best if not the best
the second-best player in the draft at
number four if you're Cleveland and
probably the third best player second or
third best player in the draft if you're
Denver and you sit tight yeah that has
always puzzled me that we always feel
like it feels like these teams these
GM's go gotta get our quarterback this
might not be the year you get your court
like the Jets moved up to three in
intrude Jets Ian you know performance
here we're moving up to three and we
don't even know who we're getting i why
am i moving up to three if i don't know
who I'm getting instead of I want to go
up to where I know who I'm getting
there's a big difference in that and I
didn't understand that move I I think
and I'm speculating off of information I
have the Giants were not willing to make
a deal when the Jets were looking to
make that deal
I think the Giants are waiting and
trying to take it basically just flees
the team like Buffalo if they're going
to make them move but remember Dave
gentlemen the GM for the Giants five
drafts of Carolina did not trade out in
the first round did not make a move in
the first round and they've won Bulls in
the second round during his tenure there
he's not a guy that wants to move around
a lot
you know if history is the indicator and
I think he wants to get a Hall of Fame
player at number two and and that's why
I think Berkeley is probably the odds-on
favorite right now for the Jets if
you're if you're giving them some credit
I think you would have to say a they
knew they had to get up there and the
Bills have been trying feverishly to get
into the top five to get their
quarterback they were able to strike
would be able to get to three and I'm
told they that they don't that that they
like Mayfield and Rosen maybe but those
are the two that they were looking at
and would be would be thrilled if it's
donal but if not they're really excited
about Baker Mayfield so if that's the
case you the odds that he's gonna be
there are really high I mean he's not
going one and he's not going to so
Mayfield closer than the three the other
thing is again if you're giving them a
lot of credit maybe they knew or had
Intel along that the Giants were very
likely to stay at number two so that
they were going to get the number two
quarterback in this draft whether that
was darn hold on their board or a Baker
Mayfield which player regardless of
position scares you make you nervous
ah I would say you start to look at
these corner backs you know I just like
Jair Alexander injured last year out of
Louisville he's gonna wind up being a
top 15 top 17 pick and just doesn't have
a ton of tape very good player Mike
Hughes has off the field incident in his
past some other issues that you gotta
sort through and a four or five to a
solid time but not in a lead time but
he's a really good player on tape so
there's just there's a little bit more
with the cornerback some of the corner
backs to to sit through and then Marcus
Davenport from UTSA he's either gonna be
the next CEO answer um he's wrong he's
wrong he's powerful if you can't see
Konza great if not I think he's going to
wind up being a bust and out of the
league in three or four years it really
is that big of a range on this young
young man why does it work this way Todd
where it feels like it's a quarterback
each week that we focus on the good and
the bad that you know right and now it
was Lamar Jackson last week and now it
feels like it's Mason Rudolph of out of
Oklahoma State this week I don't know if
there's another quarterback we squeeze
in next week but it feels like it's a
quarterback each week that we focus on
good and bad it'll be Kyle a letter from
from the University of Richmond the
spiders yeah my squad Lamar Jackson is
going to be the fifth quarterback taking
the first round at the end of the day
there's just too much there to develop
too many
explosive crates and there are teams in
the in the bottom 12 15 picks that are
looking at them and saying you know what
let's develop them what's utilize them
properly and we have the guy who was the
most explosive with the ball on his hand
college football the last two years
Mason Rudolph then is the next
quarterback in my opinion and I think
there's a pretty big drop-off now other
teams may view it differently but to me
Mason Rudolph Kyle Letta Luke Falk from
Washington State those are third-round
grades guys that you feel like you can
develop into really good backups and one
day maybe you have a case keenum
situation where he's strike gold and
he's in the right situation at the right
time and has had time to learn and
develop early in his career but you're
not banking on that and it's not a
player that's gonna come in and carry
your football team and that's what you
should ideally be getting in the first
round pick and that's right to me Sam
Darnell the one guy that you you're
gonna plug him in any situation and I
think in the long run he's going to
succeed and he's capable more so than
any of these other quarterbacks of
carrying a football team Josh Rosen
needs to be in the right place with some
veterans with a coach that will
challenge him mentally everyday and and
be able to distribute the ball very
efficiently to weapons if he has those
weapons
Josh Allen's either going to be the next
Ben Roethlisberger or he's going to wind
up being a bus depending on how he's
coached and situation he's in Baker
Mayfield is unique as well and there's a
lot of different things to sort through
there but I think he has unbelievable
instincts energy and leadership skills
and that's a pretty good jumping-off
point so this is a quarterback class I
think all four of those guys have a
chance to be really good at the next
level I think Donald's the clear-cut
best of the group but I think after that
you start to your gambling if you just
if you think you're bringing in a
quarterback who's going to be a starter
especially one that's gonna be starter
and successful early in his career
Todd McShea from the mothership NFL
Draft analysts wildest rumor you've
heard I don't know if it's a wild but
well the wildest one I heard and it
isn't true but it's some really some
people that I really you know trust the
intelligence say the Cleveland was at
one point not
ruling out the possibility of taking
quarterbacks at both picked number one
overall and number four overall that one
was pretty wild okay but they're not
going to do that obviously no no it does
but I mean we heard that at one point I
did I mean percentages wise it's not the
dumbest thing there's one out of every
two of these guys you're ratcheting up
your odds on finally getting it right
after twenty years of misery at that
position in Cleveland we were talking
earlier first hour about the 2015 draft
with Laremy Tunsil and how that was
playing out in real time now where were
you when you first heard about that
video surfacing with him with a gas mask
on taking bong hits it was literally at
the draft I mean they're like I think it
was it was right before the draft and
and I'm just calling everyone in the
league and people knew people knew about
some of the background stuff and the
runner and different things that you
know that he had been through and and
all all the stuff that's kind of come
out since then but didn't know exactly
about that video and obviously that's
that's why he fell and and the Dolphins
wound up getting a really good football
player at that number 12 spot and he was
a victim I mean he was a young kid he
was kind of you know country kid didn't
change passwords on social media had
someone exploit him and and and he lost
a good amount of money that night but
when it's all said and done he's gonna
wind up making an awful lot of money
because he's a really good starting
offensive lineman in the NFL more
bizarre that story or manti te'o
ooh Te'o
although the visual I don't know that
you can have much worse of a visual on
draft night come out and that was you
know that was a sabotage of it but did
you rather have a weirder story I really
didn't have a good a good grasp on
fishing at the time when the tale story
came out 34 30 on tail or Tunsil which
would you rather greenlight Te'o okay
yeah I think yeah because I remember
watching
the movie the documentary catfish and
then all of a sudden you realize I think
he's been catfished here and yeah
exactly and he didn't know it and it's
still bizarre though if you could if you
could get everyone to talk honestly
about what happened with the tonsil
thing and go back and dig from like high
school when he got associated with some
of the people that became trouble in his
in his life and how you got out of it
and distanced himself I think it would
not only from a draft standpoint or just
the story but also kind of college
football and how the inner workings of
some of these things that have created
some problems Todd good to talk to you
again good luck on draft day draft days
Todd McShane todd todd McShea for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show ass
[Music]